well here in berlin a big protest on
saturday
against pandemic restrictions has
ignited a debate
about the limits that can be placed on
the right to public assembly
the german minister for justice has
affirmed that right
while at the same time insisting that
rules like wearing masks
must be observed now most of the 20 000
people taking part in the protest did
not follow guidelines
which led to a number of arrests
[Applause]
saturday's protest in berlin against the
rules to fight the coronavirus
demonstrators failed to keep their
distance from each other
and they didn't wear masks either
politicians
are outraged
[Applause]
on the one hand they're exercising their
right to protest
but there are rules which they disregard
their behavior is playing with people's
lives
freedom and responsibility go hand in
hand there's the freedom to exercise
one's right to demonstrate but also a
responsibility to abide by the rules
instead of a relaxation of the
restrictions the bavarian state premier
marco zuda
would rather see a tougher enforcement
by authorities
to fight the virus people who come from
risk areas and don't take a coronavirus
test or refuse to take one
along with those who deliberately
violate the measures must face a fine
otherwise
all of this makes little sense
as infections rise in germany the best
way to deal with the pandemic
looks set to cause further debate
that debate very much in the headlines
uh this morning i'm joined now by our
political correspondent emmanuel
shays good morning emanuel observers
were very surprised taken back by the
size
of this demonstration and about who was
there
well uh in fact people came from all
over the country to that protest on
saturday twenty thousand people
uh you said it there's a mix of reasons
for that for them to be there you could
find
anti-vaxxers who really worry about a
possible
obligatory vaccine once and if a vaccine
is found
you also had a conspiracy theorist you
had
representatives of the far-right
movements and of the neo-nazi
movements as well but you also had
people uh
you know everyday people who worried
that their
fundamental rights were being um
trampled on because of the measures
being taken to try and tackle the
pandemic
now you also had signs that likened
wearing a mask to wearing a yellow star
during world war
ii or for example um there was a banner
showing
uh calling that the tag def high height
which means the day
of freedom except that this name is
actually the name of a nazi
propaganda film by eleni riefenstahl so
those signs were problematic
as well um people were calling for
angela merkel the chancellor
from chris for christian drawston who's
the main virologist
and the one who's beca who become quite
famous during that
uh pandemic for yen span to be locked up
so we see
a sea of angry people who demonstrated
on saturday in berlin
okay the politicians were very quick to
respond
to this especially considering the size
of the demonstration what were they
saying
well jen spann for example the health
ministers say that of course
people have a right to protest that's
not put in question however
if they do so without respecting social
distancing without wearing masks then
they endanger other people i've covered
for example the black lives matter all
throughout
june here in berlin and there was also
the question of how safe it was but
for example when there was the biggest
protest which gathered
15 000 people everybody was wearing a
mask so we really see two
sides of german society that are
clashing at the moment
okay not only clashing this one part of
german society
clearly rejecting guidelines that we've
been following since march
yeah exactly i think there's uh somehow
a lack of trust for one part of the
german society towards the government
and
its handling of the crisis there's also
signs of impatience and
perhaps it's more difficult to
understand here in germany because the
country
hasn't been hit so hard by the pandemic
not as hard as spain not as hard as
france or italy for example and
all things considered here in germany we
had a very mild lockdown we were still
able to go out
with a sea label to do a lot of things
that other countries couldn't yet
a lot of people feel that their
fundamental freedoms are being
threatened
okay not not as as severe as a lot of
places like like spain or france
um the lockdowns here the school's
reopening today in the german state of
mecklenburg four palm and other school
and other states that
to follow what are the guidelines for
for school reopenings
well today in uh mecca for pomeran uh
there's um a hundred fifty thousand
children
which will go back to school the plan is
to make it as normal as possible given
the circumstances they will have four to
five
teaching hours per day including music
classics sports
classes as well wearing a mask
won't be compulsory but children will be
asked to respect a
social distancing and when not possible
not to touch each other
in any case and also school years
will be divided so as to allow for one
class or one school year to be
quarantined
quarantined if there's an infection but
so as not to affect the whole school
okay so localizing also any possible
lockdowns
moving forward emmanuel thanks so much
for coming in on this today thank you
you